people interact with cloud applications
on a daily
if not hourly basis we use them to play
music
share photos and videos store passwords
and a whole lot more
it's no surprise that the number of
cloud native applications
is expected to more than double over the
next year
that's why cloud native architecture
jobs are rapidly growing
as companies seek employees who are up
to date
on cutting-edge cloud technology to meet
the demand
udacity has teamed up with the best in
the field to teach you
how to run and manage scalable
applications
in cloud native environments with the
cloud native
application architecture nanodegree
program
in this nanodegree program you will
learn how to use open source tools
and projects like argo cd grpc
and garfana you'll develop the skills to
identify the best application
architecture solution
for your organization's needs design a
micro service architecture by leveraging
cloud native tools and patterns
implement best practices in kubernetes
security
and use dashboards to diagnose
troubleshoot
and improve site reliability throughout
the program you will build a portfolio
of five real world projects
that exemplify common business cases for
the skills you've learned
there's never been a better time to
expand your cloud knowledge
enroll today in the cloud native
application architecture nanodegree
[Music]
program